This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。在《Look Back at It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是意义重大的一时刻。84年对我影响很大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯为您带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是与一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士在进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何平台上收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
也就是在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course talk about the psychology of our 20s. All right. We're going to talk about birthday anxiety today because it is my birthday. The day that this comes out, I am turning 25, 25 years old. We are halfway through the psychology
请在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要聊聊二十多岁的心理学。好的。我们今天要聊聊生日焦虑，因为今天是我的生日。这期节目播出的这一天，我25岁了，25岁了。我们正处于二十多岁
of your 20s. And the biggest question I always get is whether I'm going to do a psychology of your 30s. I have five more years to think about it. So I will answer that question a little bit closer to the date. But yeah, it's my birthday and it's bringing up a lot of feelings. But it's also probably the most peaceful, serene birthday I have had. I have never felt more comfortable with aging and more comfortable with the age that I'm at and more comfortable with what I'm choosing to do today than, ever before and it's made me really, really reflective and it's made me want to talk about
心理学的中间阶段。我收到的最大问题总是关于我是否会做一个三十多岁心理学的节目。我还有五年时间来考虑这个问题。所以我会在更接近那个日期的时候回答这个问题。但是，是的，今天是我的生日，这引发了许多情绪。但这也是我度过的最平静、最安详的生日之一。我从来没有像现在这样对变老感到如此舒适，对自己的年龄感到如此舒适，对今天选择做的事情感到如此舒适，并且这让我进行了非常深刻的反思，让我想要谈论
this experience of birthday anxiety that I've had for so long and all the stress that usually comes with gaining another year, gaining another year of life, getting another year of experiences. And I want you to note that I did not say getting older. I like to position it as something that we are given, something that we are gifted. So this year I'm in New York City. I've been in the US for like two and a half weeks for work, for work being this podcast and for mantra, of course, doing some like amazing recordings with some incredible guests that are coming out soon. And by being in New York, I know a few people, but honestly, like, I don't have a huge, broad, wide group of friends here. My boyfriend's back in Australia or my close friends,
这种我长期以来感受到的生日焦虑的经历，以及通常随着又长大一岁、又增加了一年生活经验、又获得了一年经历而带来的所有压力。请注意，我没有说“变老”。我喜欢把它定位为我们被赋予的东西，我们收到的礼物。所以今年我在纽约。我在美国待了两周半左右，为了工作，这里的工作就是这个播客，当然还有Mantra，和一些即将亮相的不可思议的嘉宾进行了一些非常棒的录音。在纽约，我认识几个人，但说实话，我在这里没有一个庞大、广泛的朋友圈。我的男朋友回澳大利亚了，或者我最要好的朋友，
my family are back in Australia. So I couldn't do like a big thing this year. I couldn't do like a big party. I couldn't like celebrate with my closest loved ones. And you know what? I think that's part of why I feel so serene about it. Like my plan is to go to a diner tonight and I'm going to get breakfast for dinner and I'm going to do my little birthday routine, which I'll talk about later in the episode that I do every single year and I have never felt more excited about it. Like I said before, this experience has not always been the case. And I am sure for many of you who are listening, you don't find that this is the common theme that defines your birthday. It's normally quite an intense experience. Birthdays are really, really reflective by nature.
我的家人都在澳大利亚。所以我今年不能办什么大活动。我不能办什么盛大的派对。我不能和我最亲爱的亲人一起庆祝。你知道吗？我认为这就是为什么我对它感到如此安详的部分原因。我的计划是今晚去一家餐馆，我要点早餐当晚餐，我要做我小小的生日日常，我会在节目后面谈到这个我每年都做的事情，我从来没有为此感到如此兴奋。就像我之前说的，这种经历并非一直如此。我相信对于你们许多在听节目的朋友来说，你们并不觉得这是定义你们生日的常见主题。这通常是一种相当激烈的体验。就其本质而言，生日确实是非常非常容易引发反思的。
You know, they demand pause, much like a new year. You know, they feel like this very specific point in time where everything from the past feels very present and you're ruminating on who you are, what you've learned, and also who you want to become. Like, you're very focused on the future. We're getting older. What if things don't work out the way I want? I have less time. I feel like my body is aging, even though if you're in your 20s, like you're still really at the peak of your youth. But all of these feelings and this contemplation is naturally very paralyzing. And that combined with the very sensitive social element as well, you know, the pressure to be around friends, the pressure to do a big thing, the pressure to have fun, all of that can create a real cocktail of complicated emotions.
你知道的，它们要求我们暂停，就像新年一样。你知道，它们感觉像是一个非常特殊的时间点，过去的一切都感觉历历在目，你会反思自己是谁，学到了什么，以及你想成为什么样的人。就像，你非常专注于未来。我们在变老。如果事情没有按照我想要的方式发展怎么办？我的时间变少了。我觉得我的身体在衰老，尽管如果你正处于二十多岁，你其实仍然处于青春的巅峰。但所有这些感觉和沉思自然是非常令人瘫痪的。再加上非常敏感的社交元素，你知道的，周围有朋友的压力，搞大型活动的压力，玩得开心的压力，所有这一切都会产生一种由复杂情绪组成的真正的大杂烩。
And surprise, surprise, a lot about this does come down to our psychology as humans, as very deep thinking creatures and creatures who nonetheless love celebrations, but also feel overwhelmed by them at times. You know, we're full of oxymorons and contradictions, it seems. but today we are going to hopefully all together feel a little bit better about birthdays. I want to talk about what makes them so difficult at times, specifically the three main reasons that we struggle with gaining another year. And then I also want to talk about why and how to rethink this process of aging
不出所料，这一切很大程度上确实归结为我们的心理——作为人类，作为思想极其深刻的生物，同时也是热爱庆祝活动却有时又被它们压得喘不过气来的生物。我们似乎充满了矛盾修辞法和自相矛盾之处。但今天我们希望能够一起让大家对生日感觉好一点。我想谈谈是什么让生日有时变得如此困难，特别是我们难以面对又长了一岁的三大原因。然后我还想谈谈为什么要以及如何重新思考这个衰老的过程，
and to rethink birthdays in general so that they are something that you look forward to, that you're excited about, that is not stressful, and that if anything, can actually bring you a lot of knowledge about yourself and a really important space to reflect and grow into this next year of who you're becoming and who you're going to be. So I know birthdays in our 20s are a big topic, and so many of you have asked me for this. So I'm going to stop rambling. And without further ado, let's talk about the psychology of birthday anxiety.
以及重新思考生日本身，这样它们就会成为你所期待的、让你兴奋的事情，而不是有压力的事，如果有什么不同的话，它们实际上可以带给你很多关于你自己的知识，并为你提供一个非常重要的空间去反思和成长，迈向你正在成为和将要成为的下一个年头。所以我知道二十多岁的生日是一个大话题，你们很多人都向我询问过这个。所以我要停止闲聊了。废话少说，让我们来聊聊生日焦虑的心理学吧。
So I think the reason that birthdays can be so psychologically, mentally, emotionally, sometimes socially taxing comes down to three specific reasons. The first is very existential reasons to do with aging, to do with progress, to do with milestones. The second comes down to expectations and the pressure to seemingly have this perfect event or this perfect experience to mark another year. And the third series of reasons, I think, are quite social reasons that have to do with loneliness, perhaps a great deal of comparison as well. So I want to talk about each of these individually, starting with very existential reasons. So I think for the longest time, the reason birthdays felt so troublesome to me was that it was a sign that I was getting older. And that is something that was very, very scary.
所以我觉得生日之所以会在心理上、精神上、情感上、有时甚至在社交上让人感到负担重重，归结为三个具体的原因。第一个是与衰老、与进步、与里程碑有关的非常存在主义的原因。第二个原因归结为期望以及似乎要举办一场完美的活动或拥有完美的经历来标志又一年的压力。第三系列原因，我认为是相当社会化的原因，可能与孤独感以及很大程度上的比较有关。所以我想逐一谈谈这些原因，首先从非常存在主义的原因开始。所以我想在很长一段时间里，生日让我感到如此麻烦的原因是，它标志着我在变老。而这是一件非常非常可怕的事情。
My perspective on aging, though, has changed. and I used to be really scared of it. I used to joke with my friends that I would be forever 22. The reason that we are scared of aging, and if you can relate to this, I'm sure you've already come to this conclusion, the reason that we are scared of aging is because we are scared of the unknown.
不过，我对衰老的看法已经改变了。我曾经真的很害怕它。我过去常常和朋友开玩笑说我要永远22岁。我们害怕衰老的原因，如果你能感同身受，我相信你已经得出了这个结论，我们害怕衰老的原因是因为我们害怕未知。
We are naturally as humans always going to feel a little bit anxious and a little bit uncomfortable with somewhere and someplace that we have never been before. You have never been. in this next year of your life. You have never been 27. You have never been 35.
作为人类，我们天生总是会对从未去过的地方和从未经历过的地方感到一丝焦虑和一丝不安。你从来没有经历过
You have never been 66. And so because of that, it feels very unknown, very uncertain, very unstable. And with that empty space and with that uncertainty, our brain likes to fill that with fear. It likes to feel that with catastrophic ideas and imaginations of what it's going to be like. And they're not always positive. The other reason that we are scared of aging, other than the fear of the unknown, is a similar fear of the unknown, and it's a fear of death. It feels like each year we are, you know, closer to the end of this journey than the beginning. I used to be very, very scared of this.
你生命的下一个年头。你从来没有27岁过。你从来没有35岁过。
And I can openly admit that and talk about it now because of how much time I have spent thinking about it and overthinking it and intellectualizing it until the cows came in. like it was an obsessive thought of me for me for so long of what happens after we die and aging is just this is just this terrible thing that's bringing me closer then i realized that aging is actually absolutely necessary because the alternative to not getting older is that you would always stay the same and that you would always stay in the same place as the same past version of you you would never be able to grow and you would never be able to experience new chapters. Turning 25, 27, 28. Yes, it's a privilege and I know a lot of people talk about how there are so many people who don't make it to that age and you should live for them and realize that it's an opportunity. Yes, that's one way of
你从来没有66岁过。正因为如此，它感觉非常未知、非常不确定、非常不稳定。伴随着那片空白和不确定性，我们的大脑喜欢用恐惧来填补它。它喜欢用灾难性的想法和对未来会是怎样的想象来填补它。它们并不总是积极的。我们害怕衰老的另一个原因，除了对未知的恐惧之外，是对未知的相似恐惧，那就是对死亡的恐惧。感觉每年我们，你知道的，都比开始时更接近这段旅程的终点。我以前非常非常害怕这一点。
seeing it, but I also think that time holds experiences. And so if this world was perfectly designed or however you want to think about it, aging is an important. part of that because aging is what brings you into the future. Aging is what brings you excitement, brings new surprises. If you were to stay 17 for your whole life, if you were to stay 25 for your whole life, you would never get to experience what it's like to be a grandparent, what it's like to be senior in your career, what it's like to, you know, own a home that you love, what it's like to gain maturity and perspective, what it's like to feel your frontal lobe develop, what it's like to feel your frontal lobe develop. That is really how I started to see it. Another way I started to see it in my
我可以公开承认这一点，现在也能谈论它，因为我花了那么多时间去思考它、过度思考它、并将它理论化，直到天荒地老。就像这曾是我很长一段时间以来的一个强迫性想法，关于我们死后会发生什么，而衰老只是这件让我更接近死亡的可怕事情。然后我意识到衰老其实是绝对必要的，因为不长大的替代方案是你将永远保持不变，你将永远作为过去的自己的那个版本停留在同一个地方，你将永远无法成长，你也永远无法体验新的篇章。迎来25岁、27岁、28岁。是的，这是一种特权，我知道很多人谈论过有多少人没能活到那个年龄，你应该为他们活着，并意识到这是一个机会。是的，这是一种看待它的方式，但我认为时间也承载着经历。所以，如果这个世界是完美设计的，或者无论你想怎么看，衰老都是其中重要的一部分，因为衰老能把你带入未来。衰老能带给你兴奋，带来新的惊喜。如果你一辈子都保持17岁，如果你一辈子都保持25岁，你将永远无法体验到成为祖父母是什么感觉，在职业生涯中成为高级管理人员是什么感觉，拥有一个你爱的家是什么感觉，获得成熟和视角是什么感觉，感受你的额叶发育是什么感觉，感受你的额叶发育是什么感觉。这确实是我开始看待它的方式。我开始在脑海中以一种感觉更舒服的方式来看待它的另一种方式是，年龄真的只是一个数字，这太陈词滥调了。我知道，但它是如此真实。它是如此真实。我在我生命中热爱的和我认识的许多人身上看到了这种哲学。所以几周前，我庆祝了我祖父的90岁生日。现在那个男人庆祝90岁生日时，他喝得比我还多。他喝得比任何21岁的人都多。他拿出了这样一瓶非常好的波特酒。他有一个巨大的生日蛋糕，他所有的朋友都在。我的妹妹们字面意义上只有18岁和，我不知道，当时大概17岁，真心地，她们在派对甚至还没结束时就离开。
brain that felt more comfortable is that age is really just a number and it's so cliche. I know, but it is so true. It is so true. And I see this philosophy reflected in so many people that I love and that I know in my life. So a couple weeks ago, I celebrated my grandfather's 90th birthday. Now that man Turn 90, he drank more than me. He drank more than any 21 year old. He pulled out like this really nice bottle of port. He had this big birthday cake, all of his friends. My sisters who are literally like 18 and, I don't know, 17 at this point, genuinely, like they left before the night was even over.
就像我祖父母是最后一批离开的。我们和他们一起步行回家，一个个微醺带醉。不仅我祖父依然这样，拥有这种青春的活力，并没有真正显老，而且他还拥有，你知道的，我们得以倾听的那么多故事的祝福。这让我意识到，你可以把你的年龄当作你需要成为什么样的人的信号，你需要成为一个变得更加暴躁的人。你需要成为一个根据社会标准变得不那么快乐、散发出的喜悦更少、从事情中找到的乐趣更少的人，但你同样可以选择把你的年龄，
Like my grandparents were the last to go. We walked home with them, all tipsy and drunk. And not only was my grandfather still this, like, had this youthful exuberance and really wasn't showing his age, but he also had, you know, the blessing of so many stories that we got to hear. And it made me realize, like, you can take your age as a sign of who you need to be and you need to be this person who becomes more grouchy. You need to be this person who, according to society, becomes less happy and exudes less joy and finds less pleasure and things, but you also have the choice to take your age,
你知道的，让它只是你出生证明上的一个数字，或者只是你驾照上的一个数字，去体现你所感受到的年龄，以及你想随身携带的那个年龄的所有积极部分。生日会带来一些负面情绪，特别是存在主义情绪的另一个原因，归结为在面对你的人生规划时感觉自己落后了。感觉自己应该取得更大的成就，感觉自己应该更有成就，然而你却站在这里环顾四周，每个人似乎都在做着这些了不起的事情，而你却迷茫了，你落后了。现在，随着你年龄的增长，这一切将只是一场追赶的游戏。如果你能感同身受，我想你所经历的与其说是生日焦虑，
you know, keep it as something that's just on your birth certificate or just on your driver's license, and embody the ages that you feel and all the positive parts of that age that you want to bring forward with you. Another reason that birthdays can bring up some negative feelings and some specifically existential feelings comes down to feeling behind when it comes to your life plans. feeling like you should be further ahead, feeling like you should be more accomplished, and yet here you are and you look around, everyone else seems to be doing these amazing things, and you're lost, and you're behind. And now, as you get older, all it's going to be is this game of catch-up. If you can relate to that, I think what you're experiencing is not so much birthday anxiety,
不如说是里程碑焦虑。这种焦虑与感觉自己没有在应该的时候达成特定的社会认可的目标有关。这确实是我们这些二十多岁的人的一个大难题。我前几天看到这样一句quoted，感觉在18岁到35岁之间，我们都在进行某种想象中的比赛，而我们并不确定这场比赛是什么，但我们知道我们落后了。这确实是我们人生中这个时期的感觉，其中很大一部分确实归结为与同龄人的比较，但也与我们似乎都能理解的那种奇怪的被灌输的蓝图进行比较。我们似乎都有这样一种奇怪的感觉：到30岁时，你知道的，我们可能应该、应该结婚了。到25岁时，我们应该知道我们的职业生涯想要做什么。到28岁时，我们应该遇到最好的朋友了。我们应该买房了。在迎来30岁之前，有这么多看似重要的里程碑要达成。问题是，所有这些里程碑都是外在的。我们不会比较像幸福这样重要的指标。我们不会比较像成长、自我认知、真实性这样重要的东西。我们不会考虑我们在情感方面以及我们内在感受方面前进了多少。我们真的只关注外在，我们的生活在其他人眼中是如何呈现的，这是一个巨大的失望、悲伤和沮丧的来源。
but milestone anxiety. Anxiety to do with feeling like you are not. hitting specific socially approved targets when you should be. Now this is a real conundrum for a lot of us in our 20s. I saw this quote the other day that it feels like between the ages of 18 and 35 we're all in some imaginary race and we're not sure what the race is but we know that we're behind. That is really what this period in our life feels like and a lot of it does come down to comparison against our peers, but also comparison against this weird indoctrinated blueprint that we all seem to understand. We all seem to have this weird sense that by 30, you know, we probably should have, should be married. By 25, we should be knowing what we
我想，生日自然而然地把这一点展现出来了。我还要说的是，我们也非常非常专注于将自己与那些过得比我们更好的人进行比较，甚至到了犯错的地步。我们经常进行我们所说的向上社会比较。明知这会让我们感觉糟糕，明知这会伤害我们的自我概念和自尊，但我们就是克制不住自己。这就像我们几乎在潜意识里、精神上说服自己，如果我对自己的现状感到足够糟糕，也许那会迫使我更努力地工作。如果我看着一个让我嫉妒的人或者让我觉得自己成就较少的人，也许这是一种奇怪的自我惩罚感，会激励我。但事实绝对不是这样的。
want to do with our career. By 28, we should have met our best friends. We should have brought a home. there are all these seemingly important milestones to hit before you reach your 30s. And the thing is, all of those milestones are external. We do not compare important measures like happiness. We do not compare important things like growth, like self-knowledge, authenticity. We don't think about how far advanced we are in terms of our emotions and how we internally feel. we are really focused on the external, how our life appears to other people, and that is a huge source of disappointment and sadness and frustration.
并没有一个我们都在朝着努力的宏大终点线。就像地球上没有一个人拥有完全相同的目标和对他们生活样子的完全相同的愿景。每个人都不一样。甚至那些达到了你想要到达的点的人，或者那些你因为达到了你想要的点而钦佩的人，他们仍然在审视自己的生活，并感到某种程度的不满。
Birthdays, I think, just really naturally bring that out. I will also say we also are very, very focused to our fault at comparing ourselves to people who are doing better than us. We often engage in what we call upward social comparison. knowing that it's going to make us feel bad, knowing that it's going to hurt our self-concept and our self-esteem, but we just can't help ourselves. It's like we almost convince ourselves subconsciously, mentally, that if I feel bad enough about where I am, maybe that will force me to work harder. If I look at someone that I'm envious of or that makes me feel less accomplished, maybe that's this weird
我绝对可以告诉你这一点。甚至可能出现这样的情况：他们在看着你，心里想：“天哪，我真希望我有这个人拥有的那么多平静。”我真希望我有这么多的时间和空间来成长。我真希望我仍然处在起点，这样我就可以做出不同的选择了。对于每一个人来说，都有东西可以用来进行比较或与之比较。所以，当你拿自己和别人比较时，他们也在和别人比较，而那个别人可能正在和你比较。
sense of self-punishment that's going to motivate me. And that is absolutely not the case. there is no big finish line that we are all working towards. Like not one single person on this planet has the exact same goals and the exact same vision of what their life looks like. It's all different. And even people who get to the point or even people who you admire for getting to the point that you want to be, they are still looking at their life and feeling some sense of dissatisfaction.
所以我知道，这可能是生日中非常非常艰难的一部分，那就是在二十多岁时感到落后和迷茫。每当我处于那个阶段时，我总是提醒自己去思考，因为我认为作为人类，我们最终都会陷入那种比较的漩涡。我总是提醒自己去回想过去一年我在个人成长和反思方面取得了什么成就。
I can absolutely tell you that. It may even be the case that they are looking at you and thinking, God, I really wish I had as much peace as this person has. I really wish I had as much time and space for growth. I really wish that I was still at the beginning so I could make different choices. There is something to be compared against or with for every single person. So as you're comparing yourself to someone else, they're comparing themselves to someone else who's probably comparing themselves to you.
所以当我迎来25岁时，我觉得在我生命的第24年里，我变得更擅长减少来自社交媒体的压力。我变得更擅长管理我的过度思考。我变得如此擅长对自己拥有的朋友感到满意，而不是觉得我不断地需要更多，或者我不断地处于孤独的边缘。对我而言，这比我在公众面前取得的任何成就都更重要，也更积极地影响着我的日常生活。这种内心的成长、稳态和进步真的非常非常重要。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我想谈谈最后两个原因，让我们对生日感到很多压力、焦虑，甚至悲伤。
So I know that that can be a really, really hard part about birthdays is feeling behind and feeling lost in your 20s. I always remind myself when I'm at that point because I think as humans we all end up in that comparison spiral. I always remind myself to think about what I've achieved in terms of personal growth and reflection in the last year.
以及我对抗这种状况的完美日常，请继续收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、体能和复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的认为种子油本质上会引起炎症吗？我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、
So as I'm turning 25, I feel like this 24th year of my life, I became so much better at feeling less pressure around social media. I became so much better in managing my overthinking. I became it so much better in feeling satisfied with the friends that I have rather than feeling like I constantly needed more or that I was constantly on the precipice of loneliness. That means more to me and that impacts me positively more on the daily than any kind of achievement that I've had publicly. That sense of inner growth and homeostasis and progress is really, really important. Okay, we are going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to talk about two of the final reasons that we feel a lot of stress, anxiety, maybe sadness around our birthdays.
更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在Iheart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克。
And my perfect routine for combating that, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model. world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled,
坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我一整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出其中有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
真的，是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某个东西的时候，我们得到了很多。我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，因为你认为在地球上时做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两种不同水平的信任。
Really, yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get a lot. It's so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我希望你能真正成为一个好人。和我，基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。埃伦斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，新闻报道称，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
请在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。每个男人都应该遵守两条黄金规则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的这一新季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。请在Iheart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何平台上收听。让我们来谈谈生日可能如此艰难的第二个原因，那就是期望。
Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid games. prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by
这就是要度过完美的一天、完美的派对、拥有所有会祝我们生日快乐的完美朋友的压力，而我们往往会感到失望。我想99%的时候，当你对一个盛大的生日派对抱有宏大的期望，并且，你知道的，你期望每个人都如何对待你时，你往往会感到失望。我认为任何时候当我们说我们应该做某事时，我们应该快乐，我们应该被爱，我们应该玩得很开心，我们应该，你知道的，只是轻松度过这一切，你就是在为自己设定失望。你知道的，当我们把“应该”或“本该”放在任何事情前面时，
a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Let's talk about the second reason that birthdays can be so hard and it's expectations.
通常它都不会呈现出我们想象中的样子。现在，我认为这也可以归结为比较，对吧？我们看到人们举办盛大的生日派对，有很多很多朋友，看起来超级好玩，他们看起来被庆祝、被爱。当然我们想要那样。那看起来太棒了。所以我们着手让它发生。我们在那些照片中、在那些图片中看不到的，
It's this pressure to have this perfect, perfect day, this perfect party, these perfect friends who are all going to wish us happy birthday. and often we are let down. I would say 99% of the time when you have grand aspirations for a big birthday blowout and, you know, how you expect everyone to treat you, you're often disappointed. I think any time we say that we are supposed to do something, we're supposed to be happy, we're supposed to be loved, we're supposed to have all this fun, we're supposed to, you know, just ease through this, you are setting yourself up for disappointment. You know, when we put should or supposed to before anything,
是举办这种盛大活动和拥有这种宏大期望通常带来的所有压力。现在，如果你是一个特别难以控制自己的人，从外表看起来可能真的很酷很有趣的大型生日派对的想法，可能会给你带来很多内在的混乱。首先，你会希望每一件事都完美进行。你可能会希望它看起来完全如你所想象的那样。而且你会为别人的快乐承担责任。如果这能引起你的共鸣请告诉我，但我经常发现，每当我举办盛大的生日派对时，
often it's not going to look the way that we have imagined it. Now, I think this also comes down to comparison, right? We see people having these huge birthdays with lots of lots of friends and it looks so fun and they look celebrated and loved. Of course we want that. That looks amazing. And so we go about trying to make that happen. The thing that we don't see in those photos, in those pictures,
我总是花大约50%的夜晚环顾四周，确保大家都在聊天，确保大家都在享受自己。我肯定在前一个小时都在想人们会不会来，在想人们会不会离开并说那不好玩或者他们会提前离开。现在，对于一个本该专注于你、专注于，你知道的，长大和体验更多这一不可思议的成就的一天来说，这样的大型活动会把所有你应该展现自己的注意力从你身上转移开，转到管理别人的感受和别人的看法上。它经常创造这样一种体验：你只能在事后诸葛亮中感到快乐。你只能戴着玫瑰色眼镜感到快乐。所以一整天，你可能都感到非常紧张、非常不知所措、非常仓促。
is all the stress that usually comes with having those kinds of huge events and huge expectations. Now, if you were someone who specifically struggles with control, the idea of like a big birthday party that might seem really impressive and fun from the outside is probably going to cause you a lot of internal chaos. For the starters, you're going to want every single thing to go perfectly. You're going to want it to perhaps look exactly as you imagined it. and you are going to feel responsible for other people's fun. Tell me if you relate to this, but I've often found whenever I have thrown big birthday parties,
然后在活动期间，也许你得到了几小时的极乐，但你仍然担心别人的感受。然后在第二天早上，有时你甚至会有一些情绪和社交宿醉。然后它可能仍然没有达到你的期望，你把钱投到了这个派对上，你把希望和梦想寄托在它上面，这会导致我们感到非常非常失望。你可能还经历过没有告诉别人你想要什么，不想成为一个负担，
I always spend about 50% of the night looking around me and making sure that people are chatting, making sure that people are enjoying themselves. I most certainly spend the first hour wondering if people are going to show up, wondering if people are going to go away and say that was fun or they're going to leave early. Now, for a day that should be focused on you and should be focused on, you know, this incredible achievement of growing up and experiencing more, I find that big events like that take all of the attention you should be showing yourself off of you and onto managing other people's feelings and other people's perceptions. It often creates this experience where you can only feel happy in hindsight. You can only feel happy with rose-tinted glasses on. So throughout the day, you've probably felt very on edge, very overwhelmed, very rushed.
不想大声说出来，“嘿，请大肆庆祝我一下，请小题大做一番”。正因为你没有沟通，每个人都以为你只想搞点小动静，你感到失望，因为你希望有人能读懂你的心思。可悲的是，他们做不到。你知道的，这就像你不能跑出去说“我想要一个惊喜生日派对”，因为那样你就不会感到惊喜了。但你的一部分心里在想“我只希望这些人能看透我的大脑，知道我想要什么”，
Then during the event, maybe you get like a couple of hours of a bit of bliss, but you're still worried about other people's feelings. And then the next morning, sometimes you even have like a bit of an emotional and social hangover. And then it still may not have met your expectations and you've put money into this party and you put your hopes and dreams into it, that can lead us to feel very, very let down. You may also have the experience of not telling people what you want, not wanting to be a burden,
即使对于我们最亲密、最近的亲友来说，有时这也是不可能的。另一方面，我也和一些人交谈过，他们对我说：“我有这些宏大的期望，但我也知道成为全场焦点会让我觉得非常尴尬。我知道我会对此感到非常奇怪，因为我有被审视的恐惧。但我忍不住觉得，如果我不这样做，我也会非常孤独，我会感到非常社交孤立。”所以这确实变成了一种进退维谷的困境。如果，你知道的，由于某种原因，你身边没有朋友，你现在感到有点
not wanting to like outwardly say, hey, please make a big deal about me, please make a fuss. And because you haven't communicated it, everyone thinks you want some small thing, you're left disappointed because you wish that someone had read your mind. And the sad thing is that they couldn't. And you know, it's like you can't go out and say like I want a surprise birthday party because then you're not surprised. But some part of you is like I just wish these people would be able to see into my brain and know what I want,
社交孤立或疏离。生日的到来真的能把那些更深的情绪置于透视之中。我觉得生日是把耀眼的聚光灯照向你感到不安全的地方的好方法。你对没有足够的朋友感到不安全吗？你对没有充分利用二十多岁感到不安全吗？你对落后感到不安全吗？你对自己的外表或年龄感到不安全吗？生日会把所有这些都带到表面上来。它会将你的孤独、你的不满、你的不安全感直接推到你脑海的最前端。所以我想要谈谈我们如何能把这件事做得更好。我们如何能过更好的生日？现在，正如我所说，作为一个曾经举办过这些盛大的生日派对，却总是最终感到有些失望和沮丧的人，我逐渐意识到我不是一个想要举行盛大狂欢庆祝活动的人，即使那是我在过去，我不知道，15年左右里真心以为自己想要的东西。就像对于我的21岁生日，我记得举行了三种不同类型的活动。就像我和家人举行了生日晚宴。我和一些朋友去旅行了，并在我生日当天去了酒吧。是的，这很有趣，但压力比收获大。所以我的新做法是选择一些我一直想做、却在过去一年里一直拖延的活动去做，即使这意味着独自完成。现在，今年碰巧意味着我独自旅行，而这确实是我一直想做的事。但就在我录制这期节目之前，我去了纽约市的排屋博物馆。那是世界上我最喜欢的博物馆。
which even for our closest, most nearest and dearest friends is sometimes impossible. On the flip side, I've also spoken to people who have said to me, I have these big expectations, but I also know that I'm going to feel very awkward being the center of attention. And I know I'm going to feel very strange about it because I have this fear of being perceived. But I can't help that feel like that if I don't do this, I'm also going to be very lonely and I'm going to feel very socially isolated. So it does become a bit of a catch-22. and if, you know, for some reason, you don't have friends around you, you're feeling a little bit
即使对于我们最亲密、最重要的朋友来说，有时这也是不可能的。另一方面，我也和一些人交流过，他们对我说，我有这些巨大的期望，但我也知道，成为关注的焦点会让我感到非常尴尬。我知道我会对此感到非常奇怪，因为我有被别人注视的恐惧。但我忍不住觉得，如果我不这样做，我也会感到非常孤独，并且会感到在社交上被孤立。所以这确实有点像一个进退两难的困境。如果你，你知道的，因为某种原因，你身边没有朋友，你现在感觉有点
socially isolated or alienated at the moment. The experience of like having a birthday pop up can really put those deeper emotions into perspective. I feel like a birthday is a great way to put a big shining spotlight on what you're feeling insecure about. Are you feeling insecure about not having enough friends? Are you feeling insecure about not making the most of your 20s? Are you feeling insecure about being behind? Are you feeling insecure about your looks or your age? A birthday is going to bring all of that to the surface. It's going to bring your loneliness, your dissatisfaction, your insecurity straight to the top of your mind. So I want to talk about how we can do this better. How can we have better birthdays? Now, as someone, as I said, who used to have these big
在社交上感到孤立或疏离。像生日这样的经历确实能让这些更深层的负面情绪更加清晰地显露出来。我觉得生日是一个极好的方式，它就像是一束耀眼的聚光灯，直接照在你感到没有安全感的地方。你是否为没有足够的朋友而感到不安？你是否为没有充分利用好自己的20多岁而感到不安？你是否为自己落后于人而感到不安？你是否为自己的外表或年龄感到不安？生日会把这一切统统带到水面上。它会把你内心的孤独、不满和不安全感直接推到你脑海的最顶端。所以我今天想谈谈我们该如何更好地应对这一切。我们该如何过好生日呢？现在，正如我刚才所说，作为一个曾经举办过这些盛大
birthday parties and always end up feeling somewhat disappointed and let down, I have come to realize that I am not someone who wants to have a big all-out celebration, even if that's something that I really thought that I've wanted for the past, I don't know, 15 odd years. Like for my 21st, I remember doing three different kind of events. Like I did a birthday dinner with my family. I went away with some of my friends and I went to the pub for like, for my actual day of my birthday. And yeah, it was fun, but it was more stressed than it's worth. So my new thing is to choose some activity that I've really wanted to do and that I've put off for the past year and to do it, even if it means doing it solo. Now, for this year, it did happen to mean that I'm solo traveling and that's
生日派对却总是感到有些失望和沮丧的人，我逐渐意识到，我并不是那种想要大肆庆祝一番的人，尽管在过去的15年里，我一直以为这是我真正想要的生活。就像我21岁生日时，我记得自己举办了三种不同形式的活动。比如我和家人吃了一顿生日晚餐，和一些朋友去旅游了，在生日当天还去了酒吧。是的，这挺有意思的，但带来的压力远超其价值。所以我的新做法是，选择一些我一直很想做、却在过去一年里一拖再拖的活动，然后去付诸实践，哪怕这意味着独自一人去做。现在，就今年而言，这恰好意味着我要独自旅行，而且
something that I really wanted to do. But just before I recorded this episode, I went to the Tenement Museum in New York City. That is my favorite museum in the world. and I booked two back-to-back tours and I went solo and I felt completely content. Maybe for you, that involves going out and getting your nails done and getting a massage and putting the money you would have spent on a fancy dinner or a party into yourself. What is something that you really wanted to do this year that you haven't had the opportunity to do? Do that on your birthday. Maybe it's the zoo.
我预订了两个连续的导览，我独自一人前往，我感到非常满足。也许对你来说，那包括出去做指甲、做按摩，把本打算花在高档晚餐或派对上的钱花在自己身上。今年有什么是你一直想做却一直没有机会做的吗？在你的生日那天去做吧。也许是去动物园。
Maybe it's a karaoke night. that is how to make yourself feel less pressure to be happy and to have fun in the presence of others and to almost like have fun by yourself. I also do this thing every year and regardless of whether I'm doing a big thing or a small thing or a completely solo thing, I make sure that around the time of my birthday I take myself out on a date. Just me and my notebook and I will go out to a restaurant. Often I will literally not have anywhere in mind. I will take myself for a walk in a part of the city that I know will have places to go.
也许可以办个卡拉OK之夜。这样能减轻对快乐的压力，在别人的陪伴下享受乐趣，或者几乎就像自己一个人玩得很开心。我每年也会做这样一件事，不管我是做一件大事、小事还是完全独自一人的事，我都会确保在生日前后带自己去约会。只有我和我的笔记本，我会去一家餐厅。通常我脑子里真的没有想好去哪里。我会带自己去我知道有地方可去的城市某个地方散步。
I will find a restaurant. I will get a table by myself. I will bring my journal and I will ask myself four questions. And I've done this every single birthday for the past five years. The questions are, what is the most important thing that I have learnt in the past year? What is the thing that I am most grateful for from the past year? what is the most important thing that I've done in the past year? And what is one thing that I really want to achieve in this next year or that I really want to experience or see?
我会找一家餐厅。我会自己坐一桌。我会带上我的日记本，问自己四个问题。在过去的五年里，每个生日我都这么做。这些问题是：过去一年我学到的最重要的东西是什么？过去一年我最感激的是什么？过去一年我做过最重要的事是什么？接下来的一年里，我真正想实现或真正想体验、看到的一件事是什么？
And then I just let myself also do some general journaling. I just let myself spill out onto the page. That's obviously what I'm going to do tonight when I go get my little breakfast for dinner situation. And I use, actually, I should have said this. I have a specific journal that I only use for this. So it's like my birthday journal. And so I'll often read back on all of my other entries. Obviously now I have so many that I kind of, well, not that many, but enough that I kind of
然后我就会让自己也写一些随笔。我只是让自己在纸上倾诉。这显然是我今晚去买我的小早餐当晚餐时要做的事。而且我用的是，其实我应该早点说的。我有一个专用的日记本，只用于这个。所以它就像是我的生日日记。因此我经常会回头阅读我所有的其他条目。显然现在我有了很多，以至于我有点，也不是说很多，但足够让我...
forget what I've said and what I've been reflecting on. So it's actually a really beautiful, serene experience to really sink into the life that I was living when I was 23 and the life that I was living when I was 22 and the problems I was having when I was 18 and I feel like I'm right there with her and yet I'm also growing and I'm also experiencing a whole different life in some aspects of it. So that routine is really, really important to me. More generally, if you are dealing with birthday anxiety, my tip is just to do less and to be totally okay with doing some things alone and making it a little bit smaller. That is always going to lead to a more happy experience, in my opinion.
忘记我说过的话以及我一直在反思的内容。所以这实际上是一个非常美丽、宁静的体验，让我真正沉浸在我23岁时过的生活、22岁时过的生活以及18岁时遇到的问题中，我觉得我就和当时的她在一起，然而我也在成长，在某些方面也在体验完全不同的生活。所以这个日常对我来说真的非常重要。更广泛地说，如果你正在应对生日焦虑，我的建议就是少做一点，完全接受独自做一些事情，把它办得小一点。依我来看，这总是会带来更快乐的体验。
I also think that instead of feeling like you need to be silent around your fears of aging or your sense of loneliness when it comes to a birthday, whatever it is, please, like, talk about it with someone. Every single time I have brought up this specific feeling of stress and worry when it comes to my birthday, the person I've spoken to has said, yeah, me too. I completely get where you're coming from. I'm very lucky that my best friend's birthday is three days after mine, so I feel like we always share these parallel experiences.
我还认为，面对生日时，与其觉得你需要对你对变老的恐惧或孤独感保持沉默，无论是什么，请和某人聊聊。每一次当我提起这种对生日特有的压力和担忧时，我聊过的人都会说，是的，我也是。我完全理解你的感受。我很幸运，我最好朋友的生日比我晚三天，所以我觉得我们总是分享这些并行的经历。
And every year we kind of have the same conversation where we're like, oh my God, another year older, like freaking out together. But we also feel this real sense of parallelness and camaraderie. And we feel like it's quite a unique bond and experience to be going through a lot of these emotions and this process of aging together. The other thing I really like to reflect on and that I think might be useful is I reflect on all the people I know
每年我们都会进行同样的对话，比如，天哪，又老了一岁，然后一起抓狂。但我们也感受到了这种真正的平行感和友情。我们觉得一起经历许多这些情绪和变老的过程是一种非常独特的羁绊和体验。我真的很喜欢反思的另一件事，而且我认为可能会有用的是，我反思了我认识的所有人...
who are five, ten years older than me. I think it's really important to have friends who are at different stages of their life than you. So I have friends who are 50. I have friends who are 35, I have friends who are 19 and it's really valuable to kind of get the lived experience and the opinions from them. and around the time of my birthday, I always think about a few of my friends who are exactly a decade
他们比我大五岁、十岁。我认为结交处于人生不同阶段的朋友非常重要。所以我有一些50岁的朋友。我有35岁的朋友，我有19岁的朋友，从他们那里获取人生阅历和意见真的很有价值。在生日前后，我总是会想起几个比我大整整十年...
older than me. Specifically, my friend Alicia and my friend Lindsay, they at 35 are the most successful, hottest, poised, richest versions of themselves that I've ever seen. And they are also the happiest. And I remember as they were turning 30, I did talk to Alicia about this. I was 20. She was 30. I think I asked some naive question around like, how do you feel about turning 30? And she was like, I'm terrified. I'm absolutely terrified. Five years later, she's like, this is the age I want to be forever. I thought that 25 was amazing. I thought the 21 was amazing. 35 is the best. Like it's, you feel so confident. You feel so much like yourself. And she also said to me, you know, my birthday is not as important as the experiences that I'm having.
的朋友。特别是我的朋友艾丽西亚（Alicia）和琳赛（Lindsay），她们在35岁时是我见过的最成功、最性感、最优雅、最富有的自己。她们也是最快乐的。我记得当她们30岁时，我确实和艾丽西亚谈过这个。我当时20岁。她30岁。我想我问了一些天真的问题，比如，你对30岁有什么感觉？她说，我很害怕。我绝对吓坏了。五年后，她说，这是我永远想呆的年龄。我曾以为25岁太棒了。我曾以为21岁太棒了。35岁是最好的。你会觉得自己太自信了。你觉得自己更像自己了。她还对我说，你知道，我的生日并不如我正在经历的体验那么重要。
Like this is less mentally straining and less mentally exhausting and there's a lot less pressure on it the older I get. And I'm just able to have fun with it. I'm just able to prioritize what I want to do. And it shows. Like she just looks amazing and she has this like shine coming out of her soul that just says I'm present. I know who I am.
这在精神上的压力越来越小，精疲力竭也越来越少，随着我年龄的增长，上面的压力也小得多。我能够从中获得乐趣。我能够优先做我想做的事。而且显而易见。她看起来就是棒极了，她身上散发着一种来自灵魂的光芒，仿佛在说我很在乎。我知道我是谁。
And I'm really deeply satisfied and happy. Whenever I feel scared about entering a new chapter in a new phase of my life, I look to people like her and I say, if they've done it, I can do it and look at how amazing it's turning out for them. And it brings me a great sense of peace. My two final, perhaps a little bit alternative tips for dealing with birthday anxiety is to actually celebrate your birthday a week afterwards so that you get over the like emotional hangover of your birthday and you feel like there's less expectations. It's just a more general celebration. And I also really hope that you engage in this mindset shift that I've been taking part in the last
我感到非常深深的满足和快乐。每当我对进入人生新篇章和新阶段感到害怕时，我会向像她这样的人看齐，然后我说，如果她们做到了，我也能做到，看看她们现在过得多么精彩。这带给我极大的平静感。对于应对生日焦虑，我的最后两个或许有点非主流的建议是：实际上在生日过后的一个星期再去庆祝，这样你就能熬过生日带来的“情绪宿醉”，并且觉得期待会少一些。这只是一个更普遍的庆祝。我也真心希望你能参与到我过去一直在采用的心态转变中...
few months, few years, which is to see my life as seasons rather than as just a bunch of years. And I've spoken about this on the podcast before. I found that life felt a lot more stressful when it felt like there was just this huge chunk of years in front of me with nothing really delineating them, nothing really setting them apart, and I was just going to speed right through them to the end. Instead, what I now see, and I think of my life as, is seasons of a TV show. And, you know, I'm still in season two. Like if every season lasts 10 years, and that's still a huge number of years, I'm still in season two. If every season last five years, I'm in season five, but I have perhaps another 15 seasons to go.
几个月，几年，那就是把我的生活看作是季节，而不是一堆年份。我以前在播客里谈过这个。我发现当感觉眼前只有一大堆年份，没有任何东西真正界定它们，没有任何东西真正把它们区分开来，而我只是要一路狂飙到终点时，生活会感觉压力大得多。相反，我现在看到并将我的生活视为：电视剧的季节。而且，你知道，我仍然在第二季。就像如果每一季持续10年，那仍然是一个巨大的数字，我仍然在第二季。如果每一季持续五年，我是在第五季，但我可能还有另外15季要走。
My math might not be right with that, but probably isn't. Yeah, but maybe if I live to 100, like it's better to see yourself as existing in these two, three, four, five-year periods where you're learning something new and you're experiencing a new part of your life. And every five years, you celebrate that milestone and you push yourself to move or to do something new instead of just thinking, okay, a year is gone,
我的数学可能算得不对，大概真的不对。是的，但也许如果我能活到100岁，把自己看作是存在于这些两、三、四、五年的周期里会更好，在这些周期里你正在学习新东西，体验生活的新部分。每隔五年，你庆祝那个里程碑，逼自己搬家或做些新事情，而不是只想着，好吧，一年过去了，
a year is gone, a year is gone, really helps me put it into perspective. Don't feel like you're behind. Please, I promise you there is someone looking at your life wishing for it. Know that if you are experiencing a ton of loneliness at this point, you feel like there's no one to celebrate you. That's just this moment. There are amazing, great, fabulous relationships coming your way. And this experience of loneliness is an important one.
一年过去了，一年过去了，这真的帮我把事情看得很透彻。不要觉得自己落后了。求你了，我向你保证，有人正看着你的生活并渴望拥有它。要知道，如果你在这个时候经历大量的孤独感，觉得没有人为你庆祝。那只是这此刻的感受。有惊人、美好、abulous的关系正向你走来。而这种孤独的体验是很重要的。
It's going to motivate you to reach out. It's going to motivate you to be connected. And I just hope this can be a more positive experience for you. I also want to thank you deeply, deeply, deeply for being with me for this past year from 24 to 25. I know I've gained so many new, loyal, wonderful listeners. Thank you for giving me the opportunity to talk about my 20s in as much depth as I want. I feel like I gain so much more from this than you guys can even imagine. and this is like a personal diary for me.
它会激励你去联系别人。它会激励你去建立联结。我只希望这能成为你一段更积极的体验。我还想深深地、深深地、深深地感谢你在过去一年里一直陪伴着我，从24岁到25岁。我知道我获得了那么多新的、忠实的、美妙的听众。谢谢你们给我机会，让我尽可能深入地谈论我的20多岁。我觉得我从中获得的收获比你们想象的还要多，这就像是我的个人日记。
And this episode specifically, you know, of course I have my journal exercise, but I'm thinking about 35-year-old Gemma or 45-year-old Gemma or 55-year-old Gemma who's going to listen to this episode and be like, wow, we were recording that in a hotel room in New York City. And we felt so much peace and being able to reflect on this moment. So thank you for giving me the opportunity to make that come true and bring the thoughts in my head alive in the form of this podcast, as always, if you have an episode suggestion, if you have further comments, questions, queries, thoughts about this episode and the topic of birthday anxiety in general, feel free to reach out to me at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram.
尤其是这一集，你知道，当然我有我的日记练习，但我在想35岁的杰玛（Gemma）或45岁的杰玛或55岁的杰玛，她会听这一集并觉得，哇，我们在纽约市的一个酒店房间里录制这个。我们感到如此平静，并能够反思这一刻。所以谢谢你们给我机会让它成为现实，并通过这个播客让脑海中的想法变得生动。像往常一样，如果你有剧集建议，如果你有进一步的评论、意见、疑问、对这一集以及关于生日焦虑这个话题的整体想法，欢迎随时在Instagram上的That Psychology Podcast联系我。
If you loved this episode, leave a comment, leave a five-star review. Make sure you're following along so that you get notified when we have more episodes coming out and coming your way. But until next time, stay safe. be kind, please be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
如果你喜欢这一集，请留个言，留个五星好评。确保你关注了我们，以便在我们有更多新节目推出时收到通知。但直到下次，保重。保持善良，请对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。在《Look Back at it》播客中。1979年，对我来说是个大时刻。84年对我来说很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't.
我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你正与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲。它向世界发出的信号是，你是不容小觑的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着...
not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
并不意味着你需要这么做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marenciini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
格雷格·吉利斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马伦奇尼（Michael Marenciini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and build. and resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
那是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和构建韧性的科学。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的.
Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
收听《2%》。即TWA%，在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由真人制作的。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。